The Joe Rogan experience.
What was your first car?
My first car was in 1973
Chevelle, Chevelle. S.
S it was a shitbox.
I drove it from the guy's house to
my house and then it died. It never,
it never worked again.
I think I drove to my girlfriend's house
and then I drove back to my house and
then it died. Yeah. And I called the guy
up my hand and your fucking car done.
He came and gave it back. He gave me the
money back and took his car. He said,
what happened to my car? I'm like,
it died. It just doesn't work. Wow.
And so you had like a day?
I had it for a day and then my,
that's horrible.
Yeah.
Then I had a 1968 four four two that
are wrapped around a telephone pole.
Oh Shit. Yeah. Whoops.
Hydroplaned yeah. Yeah.
If you didn't know how to drive back
then and you had to like kind of balding
tires. Yeah. And you hit some water. Yeah.
Cars would just go sideways. You know?
What is this like? You're floating
in the air. Yeah. It's crazy.
It's a crazy feeling.
Can't do anything about it.
Nothing about it that would tell you
to turn into it. Nothing's happening.
I was just going sideways. I was
like, I can't believe this shit.
I just got this car. I had that one
for a few months and then paying,
fuck that one up. Just hydro planning.
She was hired by herself. No,
I was with a couple of guys from a school.
It might get hurt. No, we're aren't.
Yeah, but it fucked the car up. I was
in a fee era. Remember Fierro? Yeah.
My sister had one of those. It's like
a little key chain Ferrari. Yeah.
I remember used to do so small. These
should do Ferrari kits for those. Yes.
It turned into a fake Testarossa
put a car bra on there.
Yeah. Those were, those were interesting.
My friend Joe had with those two.
Those were cool little cars.
Jim caught right back in the day.
It was like either in my hometown.
It was like, here it is a one
ridiculous car. Great. Adorable.
Those cars are so gross when people
do that. Yeah, and it's obvious. Well,
it's like, what do you, no one wants
that once you is that one that can't no,
that is that the one year old
says, wow, great job. That's crazy.
That one actually looks good.
Yeah. What's I'm looking tricks.
I'm really dumb girls with that Miami.
Right.
Let me see your cell phone to the
really dumb ones. Yeah. Like that's the,
like if you were only looking for
really dumb gals. Yeah. That's your car.
Dumb gold diggers. Those louvers.
What does that in the back? Yeah.
It looks like glass louvers. Yeah. It's
probably a plastic rear window. Oh my God.
They make some cars with plastic windows
just to save weight. Okay. Relax.
Relax with that. Yeah.
We, uh, my buddy and I,
he had one of those, we hydroplaned
spun around a couple of times.
Totaled it,
hit another car that was parked at a
body shop and they had just finished it.
No, swear to go. He's like, oh, cool. Uh,
I guess I'm doing two colors.
Just cost fixed.
Totaled by slamming into a car that
was just finished at a body shop. Yeah.
That was a
jet. That Uber is that guy's
friend. Get on down the Uber
[inaudible].